("Thunderstruck" by AC/DC)
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ I was caught ♪
♪ In the middle of a railroad track ♪
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ I looked 'round ♪
♪ And I knew there was no turning back ♪
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ My mind raced ♪
♪ And I thought what could I do ♪
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ And I knew ♪
♪ There was no help no help from you ♪
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ Sound of the drums ♪
♪ Beating in my heart ♪
♪ The thunder of guns ♪
♪ Tore me apart ♪
♪ You've been ♪
♪ Thunderstruck ♪
♪ Rode down the highway ♪
♪ Broke the limit we hit the town ♪
♪ Went through to Texas yeah
Texas and we had some fun ♪
♪ We met some girls ♪
♪ Some dancers who gave a good time ♪
♪ Broke all the rules ♪
♪ Played all the fools ♪
♪ Yeah yeah they they
they blew our minds ♪
♪ And I was shaking at the knees ♪
♪ Could I come again please ♪
♪ Yeah them ladies were too kind ♪
♪ You've been ♪
♪ Thunderstruck ♪
♪ Yeah yeah yeah thunderstruck ♪
♪ Ooh thunderstruck ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I was shaking at the knees ♪
♪ Could I come again please ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Thunderstruck ♪
♪ Yeah yeah yeah thunderstruck ♪
♪ Yeah yeah yeah said yeah ♪
♪ It's alright ♪
♪ We're doin' fine ♪
♪ Yeah it's all right ♪
♪ We're doin' fine fine fine ♪
♪ Thunderstruck ♪
♪ Yeah yeah yeah ♪
♪ Whoa baby baby ♪
♪ Thunderstruck ♪
♪ You've been thunderstruck ♪